this area but she never learns
thanks can can everyone hear me
yeah great okay so um thank you very
much for inviting me here i'm extremely
excited
and i want to mention that this talk
will be about a field that basically
came together in 2015 when we had a
program with simon's here about it it
was organized by myself mohan paturi
russell who just spoke ryan williams and
daniel marks
so i want to tell you what what this is
about
it's something called fine grain
complexity
so oop what is it so it's a field that
was kind of coming together through the
decades
and we formalized it and in 2015 we gave
it a name
how do we give it a name so we wanted to
have this program at the simons
institute so we started writing a
proposal but
we knew what it was about but we needed
to
come up with something to call it so we
sat together um
at the table and started discussing it
what should we call it should it be
problem-centric should we beat this
should be should it be there and i said
what about fine grained and then we're
like oh i don't know it doesn't quite
describe it but it is it's okay you know
uh and then eventually we said okay
let's let's go with that that's the best
we could come up with so there we go now
it's fine grain complexity
and what is what is it about i'll tell
you about it in the next few slides
um
okay
what's the motivation
so we like to design algorithms right uh
okay so what do we do
we
look at some computational problem some
problem a
and we try to come up with an algorithm
we have a lot of these techniques we put
them together and we came up with some
algorithm and we analyze it we get a
running time a of n
and then we think is a of n the best we
can do well
maybe not and then we start shaving
polylocks okay maybe we shave a little
more than a polylog and now i don't mean
a polylogin n the input size does this
work
i don't know
well it doesn't well anyway we shape
polylog in the running time so for
example if your running time is
exponential you'll be shaving polynomial
factors or maybe
sub-exponential factors but in the end
we get stuck for many of these problems
we can't seem to do much better than a
of n so we can't get a of n to the
0.9999
okay
this is a conundrum it keeps happening
over and over and over there's a lot of
these problems
you end up shaving polylogs but or you
know
sub a of n
not it went to the point something
okay so i'll give you three examples in
this slide but you can come up with so
many they're all over the place so what
is one of our favorite well our favorite
problem k set
right we have a kcnf formula on n
variables we want to know is it
satisfiable how do you do it well
you brute force try all the possible
boolean assignments plug them in then
you get a 2 to the n
time algorithms times a polynomial
that's what that star hides the
polynomial is just evaluating formula
okay
you can do better
if either clause with is constant you
can actually do better than t to the n
but c here is some constant and people
work really hard to improve on the
constant over there but for whatever
reason there's no algorithm known
that
gives you such a running time here an
improvement over two to the n and the
exponent
for some epsilon bigger than zero that
works for all the case
okay and so that's where we're stuck
okay here's another problem completely
different uh you have two sequences over
some finite alphabet and you want to
know what is the longest sequence that
appears in both of them the longest
common subsequence
this is a problem we teach in our
algorithms classes there it's a
prime example of dynamic programming you
can run
write a dynamic programming table you
get an n squared time algorithm and
people have tried for a long time to
prove over n squared
message and patterson got n squared over
log squared of n that's the best known
um
so we say follow logs but we don't have
n to the 1.99
so again it's like some function to the
one minus epsilon which is what we can't
get
and there's another one this is from the
graph algorithms community again we're
teaching in the undergraduate undergrad
algorithms classes we have a graph that
is given on n vertices you can think of
it as dense you know it could have
integer edge weights and you want to
compute all the shortest paths distances
there's n squared of them
and if you run floyd warshall you get n
cubed and then cube time algorithm if
your weights are not negative you can
run dijkstra from every node again we
get n cubed
ryan williams was able to shave a lot of
logs in fact all the all the polylogs so
we got n cubed over 2 to the square root
log n but unfortunately that is not
sharing a polynomial so we still don't
have better than n cubed in this sense
so as you can see we have this sort of
the same story and this happens all over
um
okay but what can we say in
in complexity well we know well this
problem is very famous it's np complete
right that means if we believe p is not
equal to np this problem will not have a
polynomial time algorithm
so it's hard right except it's not as
hard as we want it to be harder maybe
you know we believe it to be hard so
there's a huge gap between
polynomial and two to the n so np
completeness says nothing about
improving over brute force search here
it also has this other issue but these
problems here are already in polynomial
time so they're not nd complete and less
equals to empty so np completeness is
not going to tell us anything about why
we're stuck on those but yet is the same
sort of phenomenon happening for all
these problems and um we want to know
are we actually stuck for the same
reason
maybe we are maybe they're all
equivalent in some sense right could be
so
that's what we want to answer in finding
complexity
okay so how do we do it it's so we want
to kind of mimic np completeness so
we're going to come up with some
hardness hypothesis kind of like p
naught equal and p except
for a variety of reasons we end up
needing more hypotheses
and they're problem-centric as you'll
see
then we take these hard key heart
problems and their hypotheses and we
reduce the problems in some
specialized ways to all the problems on
which we're stuck on and i have to tell
you what the reduction is and i will and
then in the end we hope to show that
they're all equivalent we're not there
yet but we have
equivalences okay and the interesting
thing about the equivalences is that
they're about problems that have
different running times sometimes which
is nice
okay
so
good so first i'm going to tell you
the three or four depending on how you
think of it
key hard problems that we focus on and
the hypotheses that come come out of
them
so the first one first heart problem is
sat
and there's a very nice hypothesis the
strong exponential time hypothesis uh
about set which basically says that for
every epsilon there's some clause with k
for which you cannot solve k satin 2 to
the n to the 1 minus epsilon times
and this hypothesis was kind of hinted
in a paper by russell and
paturi and zayn in 2001 but actually
wasn't named until 2010 so we have to
recite calabria in polazo and factory
from 2010 even though it's older
so
we can now we use this hypothesis to
explain a lot of stuff
and it turns out that there's another
problem in polynomial time that's really
related to this
this is this orthogonal vectors problem
so
here
you're given
a set
of n vectors they're very short of
dimension d
d is poly log n think of it it has to be
at least log n
in their binary zero one so think of
this as a version of said disjointness
think of having
n vectors over a tiny universe of size d
what do you want you want the vectors to
be your top you want to know if the set
contains two vectors that are orthogonal
in the set disjointness world you want
to know if the set of sets contains two
sets that are disjoint
okay so it's very easy to solve this
problem and n squared times d time by
taking every pair of vectors and
computing the inner product
you can do a little better if the
dimension is log n you can do better
than n squared but this is basically
shaving
polylocks
shaving stuff so there is a hypothesis
that says that this orthogonal vectors
problem is really hard it essentially
requires n squared times
i forgot to mention we always have to
fix our model of computation because we
actually care about exact running times
so i'll fix it to the word word ram
model of computation or an order login
size so a nice paper by ryan williams in
2004 2005 the journal versions 2005
shows that if you believe the strong
exponential time hypothesis you better
believe that orthogonal vectors is also
hard because you can reduce set
orthogonal vectors in the sense that any
n to the 1.999 time algorithm for
orthogonal vectors would give you a
better than brute force running time for
set you'll get 1.999 to the n percent
so
in fact we think that even if the strong
exponential time hypothesis fails this
orthogonal vector's problem could still
be hard so
there's some reasons to believe but
anyway there's these two problems and
often the reductions that we get from
sat actually go through some orthogonal
vectors are a version of it
another problem that comes from
algorithms of graph algorithms is all
pressure is passed as i mentioned
earlier and the associated hypothesis is
that
all pressures pass on dense graphs on n
nodes even when the edge weights are
integers between one and n to the c c is
100 let's say
this problem requires n cubed time and
to the 3 minus little of one time
so this uh
hypothesis was kind of swimming around
in the graph algorithms literature
people's people said oh i don't know we
don't know if we can solve this problem
very fast because otherwise we get a
better than n cube time algorithm for
gra for all pair shortest paths and we
have no idea how to do that so it's
hopeless
but that nobody actually named it but we
did so
there we go the all pair shortest path
hypothesis
and here's another hypothesis this is
from computational geometry
there was this very nice paper
by
i can't pronounce this name i'm sorry
guyantan and over mars okay so they have
this paper uh that sent that said that
if this threesome problem uh
requires n squared time then a huge
number of computational geometry
problems would
would be hard in a sense so what is
three sum you're given a set of n
numbers integers here and you want to
know if three of the numbers in the set
sum to zero
of course you can solve this and then
square time n squared log n is super
easy you just try every pair of numbers
in your set hash them uh
hash their sum and then check for the
other numbers of the negative the
numbers in the set um
uh but you can also do exactly n squared
and doing better than n squared seems
hard but there's a you can shave a
polylog over there and the hypothesis
says you can't do better than a squared
for the original paper um in 1995 said
that he actually can't do better than a
squared even by polylog but that was
refuted by that 2005 paper and now our
new fine-grained hypothesis is that you
need them to the two minus little of one
time and these are the main hardness
hypotheses we use
why is there not one because we cannot
show that they're equivalent and there's
some papers that suggest that maybe
they're not equivalent
okay so that's that's what we have
you can add many many more problems and
hypothesis if you want but these these
ones already uh explain a whole lot so
i'll just focus on these
so now i'm going to tell you what the
what a fine grain reduction is so we
can't just use any any sort of
polynomial time reduction we have to be
more careful in how we define reductions
so
let's define what reduction we mean so
we have two problems a and b and some
running times a of n and b of n and you
want to say that
uh improving over b of n for b would
improve over a of n for a that's what
our reduction was
should imply so here's how i defined it
in 2010
if you think about it
so we say
that a is a b reducible to problem b
if
for every epsilon there's some delta
so the and an a of n to the one minus
delta time algorithm that looks like
this
it runs in a of n to the one minus delta
time it solves a problem an instance of
problem a using oracle calls to problem
b
but the sizes of the calls could be
different
and the only condition is this red
inequality over there that says that the
sum
of b of n sub i to the 1 minus epsilon
over all these instances i over here is
less than a of n to the 1 minus delta
what does that mean it means that if
there exists some epsilon bigger than
zero so that b can be solved faster than
b of n time and it says that order b of
n to the one minus epsilon you can take
that algorithm and replace the oracle
calls with the run of the algorithm
then the run then you can solve problem
a in a running time which is uh the
reduction running time plus that sum
over there which is the sum of the
running times of all the uh
all the instances that your algorithm
created
and then you will get that if b if for
some epsilon b is in b of n to the one
minus epsilon time then there exists
some delta so that a is a over in a of n
to the one minus delta time epsilon and
delta could be different but the point
is that if epsilon is bigger than zero
then there's some delta that is also
bigger than zero so improving over b of
n
substantially you would will allow you
to improve over a of n substantially and
this is the key definition that we
needed because now you can show
equivalences that are more flexible you
don't want to have equivalent
if you only restrict yourself to
equivalences where the running times are
exactly the same you won't be able to
prove as much as when you allow
flexibility
and
yeah we can prove very interesting
equivalence
okay
so this is maybe the most technical
thing that i'm going to say today but i
want to
flash a slide over here with a bunch of
stuff people have shown and this is
definitely
very far from complete there's so much
so many papers that have happened since
i first drew this slide
from
threesome as i said that there was this
huge literature in computational
geometry where if you assume threesome
requires n squared time then a lot of
problems in computational geometry also
require an n squared time and a bunch of
problems in sequence alignment also
require and square time
if you take go from k sat and go through
orthogonal vectors you can show that a
lot of problems
are also required and squared in time
and other running times
for all pair shortest paths we have a
bunch of equivalences
so all pair shortest path is for example
equivalent to finding the shortest cycle
in a graph or computing the length of
the shortest cycle and things like this
and also there's a lot of problems that
you can show hardness for
from all three
but
you know this is an ever-growing field
and we're learning more and more and
we're still trying to see whether these
three are equivalent
now what i'm going to do in the uh for
the rest of the talk i'm going to tell
you how um orthogonal vectors and k sat
that give you something for the graph
diameter problem something very
interesting to me so let me let me show
you that
okay this is about graph diameter
approximation
what's the diameter of a graph so
imagine we have a graph
it could be directed or undirected
waiter unweighted will focus on
undirected and weighted because it's the
simplest
do you do you view v is the shortest
path distance between u and v where u
and v in vertices in the graph
the diameter is the largest shortest
path distance so the max over uv of duv
and we want to compute it
okay
how do we compute it well we can compute
all the pairwise distances of the graph
right and take the maximum
so we solve all pair shortest paths all
pair shortest paths is a very
computationally intensive problem
so if your graph is dense uh you as i
mentioned ryan's algorithm runs an n
cubed over two to the square of log n
which is very slow if the graph is
unweighted i give this as a graduate
exercise in my class you can do n to the
omega major the matrix multiplication
running time and you can solve the
problem then very slow
for sparse graphs you can do a little
better so petty show that you can do m n
plus n squared log log n m is the number
of edges
and the graph is unweighted of course
you can run bfs from every node
so you get mn
so let's focus on various sparse graphs
where m is essentially n and poly log n
so that's what that l tilde is then all
pressure is passed runs in n squared
time and square poly log n time
and
the output of all pressures passes n
square distances whereas the output of
diameter is one this one
number why do i need to spend n square
time to find one number
right
do we need it
and what if we settle for approximation
okay so let me talk about approximation
very quickly
here's a folklore algorithm for
approximating diameter
we're in the world where the number of
edges is basically n the number of
vertices um
let a and b are the end points of the
diameter path so there's some two
vertices so that their distance is the
diameter we don't know a and b okay we
would like to know them
so
there's a and b their distance is d this
diameter
what we can do is we can pick an
arbitrary vertex v
right
and run bfs from v
there we go
then we output the largest distance that
we found
the maximum over all the distances from
leaf to every node u
so
in particular the algorithm will
consider a and b
right okay
now
this looks like a triangle even though
it's wavy so we're going to use the
triangle inequality
if the distance between v and a is less
than d over 2 then the distance from v
to b must be at least d over 2 otherwise
the distance from a to b will be less
than d
okay so this means that what this
algorithm outputs is something that's at
least g over 2 and it's at most d
because it's a distance
and the running time is basically linear
because you run one single bfs
and it's super simple
but why can't we get a 1.9 approximation
in linear time why do we get two
why can't i get one plus epsilon
approximation
so that's a question we would like to
answer and this is what fine grain
complexity gives us an answer for
so here's two algorithms you can read
this but it's better to look at it in a
picture here's a picture so
remember we're in the sparse world where
the number of vertices and the number of
edges are the same on this axis is going
to be our approximation factor it goes
from one to two because we know that one
is an exact answer two is a two
approximation
uh here we have the exponent of the
running time
okay so n to this where you see so that
you can get an end to the c time
algorithm over there that red dot is the
algorithm that computes all the
distances in n squared time it's an
exact algorithm runs bfs from every node
here's that algorithm on the previous
slide where i run bfs from a single node
it gives you two approximation
there
here there is another red dot that
we obtained
leonardo di and i got in 2013. it's an
end to the 1.1.5 time algorithm that
gives you a 1.5 approximation and then
there's these
many many many dots over here that only
work for undirected graphs
by a paper by cairo grassy and rizzi and
basically they go to two the
approximation ratio goes to two but it's
uh it's basically 2 minus 1 over 2 to
the k so it's not linear it's like an
exponential sort of decay for 2.
so
are these the best possible algorithms
i don't know okay but this is what we're
going to answer
how do we answer it well it turns out
that you can go and i'm not going to
prove this to you but it turns out that
the answer is to look at a version of
orthogonal vectors
called k orthogonal vectors so
orthogonal vectors is as i said as given
a set of vectors you want to know if two
of them are orthogonal
and k orthogonal vectors you're given a
set of vectors you want to know if k of
them are orthogonal in the sense of
generalized inner product
what it's asking is is it true that for
every coordinate at least one of the
vectors is zero in that coordinate right
okay so that
um
that problem requires and to decay time
if you believe that the strong
exponential time hypothesis is false is
true
and that kind of follows by an argument
that ryan made a while back
so now we have this problem that is
parameterized by k and you have enter
the k running times and you use that to
create some
reduction and i'm not going to tell you
exactly what it does but basically you
take your kov instance and you create a
graph whose number whose size is n to
the k minus 1 but you're trying to beat
an end to the k time algorithm so you're
getting some running times that approach
linear time as k grows and you hope that
the approximate
approximation factor you want to beat
goes to 2. so it's a bunch of words so
i'm going to show you a picture
there's a picture
and the theorem we showed in
last year was that for every k
over there um there is
if you have a very fast algorithm an n
to the one plus one over k minus one
minus epsilon time algorithm that gives
you a two minus one over k approximation
uh then seth is false so what does that
mean on the picture it means that you
can draw this step function over here
that nicely goes through all the three
red dots the three algorithms we have
and it shows that there's no algorithms
underneath that line
so that means that all these red dots
these red algorithms are optimal under
strong a th
in particular you will not be able to
get a better than two approximation in
near linear time if you believe the
strong explanation i have a hypothesis
okay
we didn't get this from the ether okay
so how did it come up
um so in 2013 liam roddy and i observed
that you can easily reduce orthogonal
vectors to distinguishing whether the
diameter of a graph is between is either
two or three so that showed this this
this dot in a sense is optimal so in the
sense that if you want a better
approximation your running time goes to
n squared
then in 2018 with backhorse
rodity
seagal
and nicole wine we showed that it's
optimal in the other sense so you want
if you want to improve the running time
your approximation factor goes to 1.6
then
ray lisa actually goes to 5 over 3 okay
he improved a little bit
then bonnet in 2020 showed that if you
uh if the running time is n to the
fourth thirds then the approximation
factor blows up to seven over four or
something and then we finished it up
but how first rayleigh and my students
mean uh delivered nicole wine did it for
director graphs by adding some directed
edges in the gadgets
and then we were stuck for a long time
because directed edges really help
and then we could create a completely
different construction they also work
for 100 grams
but in the end what that shows
is that
with with fine grain complexity you can
show that you can get these
approximation running time tradeoffs and
you can show that they're optimal and
what's left over here is to
bring these orange dots down and show
that there's algorithms at every step
over here and that's what we're working
on right now
so i think that's true but we got to
work on it okay so that's all for
diameter and i have one more last slide
that keeps you away from lunch
okay
so
here's the last slide it's on a few
extra developments
so what else has been happening so
there's this uh trend to try to develop
something called fine grain cryptography
so what is that um
imagine that for some reason p equals np
then are we
dead maybe everything is gone well maybe
we can still have some sort of weak
notion of cryptography that could still
work out and so uh then you would say
well maybe even if p equals np maybe
three sum still requires n squared time
or maybe all pair shortest path too
requires n-cube time we don't have a way
to show that
these things
are related and then
then maybe we can still salvage
something out of this so there's been
this work by ball rosen
sabin and rasul devan that started this
uh this field saying let's build
cryptographic protocols from
fine-grained assumptions
and we had a paper along these lines as
well
but then it kind of requires that you
have worst case to average case
reductions in fine grain complexity from
the for the fine grain problems
so
the original work developed these
reductions where you take these fine
grain problems like threesome
orthogonal vectors and then create these
other specialized polynomials sort of
problems algebraic problems that are
hard on average and you can plan stuff
in them and so on
and then we try to get some more
combinatorial looking problems but we
weren't quite there and so what we if we
would really want to show that the
original uh problem fine grain problems
are hard on average that turns out not
to be true for some of them for example
for orthogonal vectors
so
interestingly enough all these problems
are about counting problems so what
about looking at counting complexity we
know that uh for a lot of problems for
example for graph matching when you
start counting the objects the problems
become super super hard right so what
about the problems that we have uh
three small pair shortest paths and uh
orthogonal vectors what if we want to
know
how hard they are to count okay so
there was some work by dell and
lipinskis and also developed because it
makes it show that approximate counting
is equivalent to decision
okay so maybe that's not that surprising
however in some very bizarre work that
we just had
with timothy chan and my student yin
jian chu we showed that threesome for
example is
equivalent to its counting version
it doesn't make any sense to me but it
is true
so if you can count the num if you can
decide whether there is a threesome
solution you can also count the number
of threesome solutions in
sub quadratic time
what does that mean we still don't know
but we're thinking about it so anyway
that's all i wanted to say thank you
again for having
questions
all right it looks like we'll take the
questions at lunch time
thank you
[Applause]